when you see some of the criticism and  you've gotten quite a bit of it that  you're protecting the president that  you're enabling the president what's  your response to that well I live in a  hyper partisan age where people no  longer really pay attention the  substance of what said but as to who  says it and what side they're on and  what its political ramifications are the  Department of Justice is all about the  law and the facts and the substance and  I'm gonna make the decisions based on  the law and the facts and I realize  that's in tension with the political  climate we live in because people are  more interested in getting their way  politically so I think it just goes with  the territory of being Attorney General  in a hyper-partisan period of time